this is a production of cornell
university
i'm phil griffiths also go by griff i'm
a vegetable breeder here at cornell
agritech i'm also part of the school of
integrative plant science
my focus
is
on primarily
brassica vegetables
but i also do work on small fruited
tomatoes and common bean
probably about
15 16 years ago it was becoming quite
clear in vegetables at least that
quality was becoming a lot more
important generally
consumers would be in
more involved in food systems and
helping to
drive changes
based on purchasing decisions
so around that time i started to
make quite a few changes away from
traditional efforts like disease
resistance adaptation
yield and more towards selecting quality
traits among the vegetables i work on
one of the
first efforts
started in about 2004
and that was getting a lot of the
variation that exists in the heirloom
tomatoes
that's a project that's still going on
today
uh these almost finished high tunnels
that we have here
uh that's some advanced lines from that
project they're all
primarily
indeterminate small fruited types
and they're aimed at the developing uh
medley groups that you see more commonly
in supermarkets farmers markets etc
so among the types i've been working on
i've got at least eight different colors
because you can have colors like light
orange peach and dark orange just within
the orange group
and about eight different fruit shapes
so i've been developing tomatoes that
are chili shaped finger shaped baby bell
pepper shaped
baby beef steak shaped baby pear
and also some of the traditional cherry
grape types
so these feed into
that
consumer preference of wanting
some variability in appearance
taste texture
and just making foods more colorful and
fun essentially
so we're starting to see quite a bit of
interest with that pickup we have um
some of the early stuff out with high
mowing seeds for the galaxy suite we're
currently testing with
wegman supermarkets here in upstate new
york in
the rochester and canandaigua area
and looking on
how we can
promote these sort of higher quality um
variable types with the small fruit
where you have the individual bite which
is ultimately what consumers prefer
so
a lot of that
selection is done in upstate new york
where we get a lot of
lights early blight uh septoria blights
particularly
uh growing the advanced selections in
tunnels helps considerably with that
these tunnels were recently constructed
so the planting is a little bit late
this year we just uh
pruned and trellised the plants it's
early july and muddy here
but these plants now will probably be
ten times the size in about three or
four weeks
but it it represents some
diversity
of
genotypes and germplasm
that really contribute to making food a
little bit more interesting in
in common being we've also gone in the
same direction
i have now uh mini kidney beans black
kidney beans
purple kidney beans
ones that
you might say are familiar but also
different people are familiar of course
with dark reds so moving to purple or
black
is
not that much of a change
so my main crop
group
is the brassica vegetables
they comprise um
probably
50 or 100 different
market classes because even within
cabbage you can have
savoy and red and flat dutch etc
so traditionally it's had more focus on
cabbage which of course we still work on
developing f1 hybrids of rose cabbage
for testing currently
and also the the other main market
classes of brassica-like broccoli and
cauliflower
more recently over the last decade or so
uh that focus has moved a lot to
the leafy brassicas
uh the kales
and the kale groupings
uh that started probably about 2008 when
i started working on sukuma wiki in
eastern africa which is an
african kale type
and then as the market for kale started
to develop in the u.s for
salad markets in particular
a lot of those efforts started to
get um
sort of fused in
to a common focus of selecting for uh
color and shape in the leafy types
so there's a lot of variation among the
market classes of brassicas
you have brussels sprouts with um
auxiliary buds cabbages essentially a
terminal bud
but
in screen and a lot of the germplasm
we started to focus a lot on
leaf color
uh that included uh the the yellow
golden leaf color that's found in
cabbage collard
uh we started that project in about 2009
2010.
and also started to focus on a lot of
anthocyanins which produced the the
purple colors in
the leaves of the brassicas uh looking
at
brassicas as a source of natural colors
with anthocyanins
so as
consumer demand for
different and more diverse products has
occurred
these different projects have really
started to come together
with the different colors shapes and
work that we're doing in
the different groups
broccoli is the
primary
brassica vegetable
in the u.s
it is also a bit of a one-hit wonder
it's
dominated primarily by the crown cut
market even though you get some
sprouting
types for example
i've been part of the
scri east coast broccoli project for the
last 10 11 years
and that's been a multi-state effort to
try and develop broccoli better suited
to
the climatic conditions on the east
coast
and as part of that effort we've been
developing materials that are more
tolerant for instance
of heat
when it comes to the crown
quality
and that's involved a lot of regional
testing working with
a lot of the big seed companies like
seminars and gender beijing
and right now we have a couple of
uh co-hybrids in advanced trials with
those companies as
varieties that
i would suit not just the east coast but
also
other areas where you have more variable
climate
that effort has been a lot of focus on
developing inbreds cms lines
complementation
but it's also merged with
efforts for
color and diversity that i've had across
the cabbage groups
so broccoli tends to fall in the
the lighter green to darker blue-green
leaf type
and you also see that in the broccoli
crown
so most of the broccoli crowns are
a dark green to a blue-green color
but what we've been trying to do is to
try and
expand out that variation a little bit
to create new and different market
classes of broccoli
the plants that i have here are actually
uh f1 combinations from the greenhouse
so they don't fully show
the trait differences
but this is a hybrid between regular
broccoli and golden broccoli
so it's intermediate in leaf color and
in crown color
if it was later in the season we'd have
the golden broccolis in the field
we also have combinations with kale
material to form uh tuscan broccoli
which has this savoy leaf type in the
broccoli background
and we brought in the anthocyanins for
burgundy broccoli
so
while you have golden broccoli tuscan
broccoli and burgundy broccoli
in these cases they're all intermediate
because they've been crossed to the
regular broccoli
leaf types
but it will give opportunities then to
have more color variation in broccoli
grounds than sprouts and
we've also found through preliminary
nutritional and consumer studies
that you get different
tastes
textures and eating qualities from
the different colored brassicas
so for instance if you have the
the golden
type of colored or kale
they tend to be
milder
more
tender
where if you have the more blue-green
type they tend to be
maybe a little bit more bitter
a little tougher
so
the kale effort is interesting because
it initiated as i mentioned in east
africa probably thirteen or fourteen
years ago
uh sakura wiki or african kale uh sakura
wiki in swahili means to push the week
have enough food for the week it's a
it's a brassica that you can harvest
weekly throughout the season instead of
risking everything on a single crop like
a cabbage or a broccoli
so we'd initially started off with that
project with uh blackrock resistance but
as the u.s kale market developed
we really started to put a big effort in
that direction
kale is a bit of a generic term for a
leafy brassica
primarily there are
the curly types which are the most
common the boracle types
there's the uh the savoid or crinkle
types which are the lacinato or the
tuscan
and there's the flat leaf types which
are the collards kale the forage kale
types
so we also see the jagged leaf types but
that's more associated with the the
russian or siberian kales which are in
the brassica naples group not in the
brassica roller racing group
a large focus over the last few years
has been on
the lacinato type
there's certain benefits to working on
it in the fact it tends to have
more self compatibility for seed
production
and like broccoli it's also a pretty
limited group the cavallo de niro
lacinato dinosaur type it tends to just
be this blue green crinkle type
of ops that are not particularly
vigorous
so among the quality traits we've been
bringing in the leaf color differences
and the
the color from the anthocyanin
so instead of
the blue green type
we can then end up with
leaf types that have the golden leaf or
the green leaf type
that's determined genetically and by
the wax content
on the leaf
but what we're also able to do is
combine
the
leaf type with um the anthocyanins
so we can start producing for example um
golden tuscan kale with a purple vein
or
we can produce
um
green tuscan with a purple vein
or blue-green tuscan with a purple vein
the association among consumers with
kale is typically is a dark leafy green
vegetable
a lot of the mainstream
salad crops tend to be more golden green
if you look at romaine or arugula
and so the familiarity is perhaps more
in the golden green category
so while we have
limited materials to show because it's
early in the season and these are just
out of the greenhouse
what we've been doing is having a focus
on a
a diverse medley
of
tuscan kale types
working on golden tuscan green tuscan
blue green tuscan purple tuscan
and also a golden tuscan with a purple
vein green tuscan with a purple vein
and we can also then put that into a
tuscan collard type and we have a lot in
that group tuscan having the savoy as
opposed to
say a flat leaf collard like this which
would be
a golden colored with a
purple vein
so
having them all in the same market class
background has some
interesting benefits from a sort of
spring mix standpoint because
you can
grow them in the same area under the
same conditions
and you're going to have a similar
product that just varies a lot with
color
but it's also going to vary somewhat
with the
eaten texture
and appearance
the
u.s market for leafy brassicas is
dominated
by the salad market
and there's certain
criteria
that
make a leafy type desirable for the
salad market
a lot of that is determined
by
this texture and structure
within the leaf
when you produce a salad the texture
will
contribute a
number of um
traits of importance
the volume it gives it makes the meal
look larger
and the texture gives it more
structure and
shelf
life stability
but it also helps to develop a crunch uh
to be able to hold the salad dressing
for example food scientists
maybe wouldn't agree in the fact that if
you have a very crinkled or very curly
type
there's more places for pathogens to
hide outer but there's also more places
for the
salad dressing to attach to and hide
after that
so an effort
currently is
focused on
the
kale types primarily within the tuscan
but also within the curly and the flat
leaf
for the mature markets
with an increase in focus on the baby
green markets
the baby green markets
are a group that
are increasing significantly for
multiple reasons
including
technology and venture capital
investment in things like vertical farms
people always also
have a higher demand for pre-mixed
spring green salads
and in that they like a lot of
difference in
color texture
and
shape
and taste among
the crops
so right now we're also trying to take
these groups and find which ones might
be more suited to
the baby green
uh market
uh particularly ones that
add something that's
a little bit more
diverse or
unusual to the mix
the
tuscan kales certainly fall in to that
category
the curly kale's less so because seed
production is more difficult
and the flat leaf less so because the
flat leaf
doesn't have that crunch salad dress
intends to slip off it
and they tend to be um
more for the uh the cooked market than
from the raw
leafy green market
there
certainly
is demand
for uh leaf structure
and shape
changes
so that's something that we have been
increasingly looking at
trying to identify lines that are
vigorous seed producers
so these are what i would call jagged
leaf selections
and you could see
that we can take a
highly jagged leaf
we could take a
moderately jagged leaf or we could take
a flatter
jacket leaf
so there's variations in
the extent
of
how jagged the leaf is
people are more familiar with this in
the the russian kale background um red
russian white russian siberian frills
fizz is a brassica roller racing that's
out there from tozer that has some
jagged leaf look to it
but what we're looking at these for
primarily is the baby green market not
the mature market
with the expansion of
the vertical farms
the expansion of the organic spring
green mixers
and the expansion of brassicas within
spring mixes to start with
uh we're looking at lines that will
contribute
some um
unique looks and types
while also being functional for
the seed production
so
we're looking at these with a number of
companies and
we can take the highly jagged the
moderately jagged
or we could even do uh
a really incredibly jagged type as a
mature
type and
combined in the pigmented leaf type
so
the brassicas are generally a very
interesting group
they have a common and established
association with nutrition
um kale is high in
a number of vitamins vitamin a vitamin k
it's also high in
um some of the carotenoids
like zeaxanthin and lutein that are
important in macular or eye health
so
increasing their presence in spring
green mixes
as
both desirable
and i think
offers huge opportunity just because of
the huge variation that exists within
brassica roller racia as a species
so a lot of what we've already been
doing is focused on
the look and the color and the taste and
the texture
but it's really a type of a fusion
breeden you might say
so taking
taking desirable consumer traits from
one market class
introducing them to
another market class
and by doing that we've been able to
introduce the golden leaf trait to
several market classes of brassicas
and they are now starting to get into
advanced testing and line development
both as releases as ops but also as
releases as f1 cms
hybrids
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu